hey it's priyanka so far we've looked at
how critter junction was able to launch
a new app on google cloud today let's
take a look at how they can enable their
apps to gracefully handle peaks
and dips in traffic
[Music]
critter junction is becoming very
popular with more users than ever
the game is all about playing daily
collecting items and furniture to
decorate your house
and interacting with other players as we
saw in the previous episode they have a
range of compute
options to deploy their workloads but
they chose to migrate
some game servers to compute engine as
their traffic grew
they were struggling to provision
additional instances globally for any
time of the day
this led to over utilized compute and
created constant pressure on their
operations teams
clearly they need an automated way to
handle their growing users
and maintain performance to keep their
users coming back daily
so let's see what printer junction
should do
they should use a global load balancer
and managed instance groups to scale
and distribute the traffic automatically
this keeps the operations team happy
and the user satisfied with great
performance
managed instance groups provide features
such as auto scaling
auto healing auto updating and regional
multiple zone deployments to understand
this better
let's step back and understand how a
compute engine instance is created
you create a custom image for your
application
which is then used to create an instance
and to make this reusable
you create an instance template in an
instance template you can not only set
up configuration of the vm
but also run startup scripts to pull
down the latest version of your code
when the machine starts up you can also
attach disk templates with all the
software dependencies your app requires
or you leave it as an empty shell that
gets populated by a ci cd pipeline
these templates then automate the
creation of compute engine
instances at scale through managed
instance groups
let's see how this works with a simple
web app example
let's head over to our project in the
google cloud console and create
a firewall rule under vpc networks to
allow
http traffic to the app we are about to
deploy
provide a name default allow http
default network targets select the
specific
target tags and set the target tag as
http dash server set the source filter
to ip ranges and provide 0.0.0.0.0
to allow access for all ip addresses
for ports and protocols select tcp and
enter
80 and then create
now head over to the compute engine and
create an instance template
give it a name select machine type set
boot disk image to debian 9
and check allow http traffic under the
management tab
find automation and add the startup
script
this script causes each instance to run
a simple
web application during startup and
finally create
link to the tutorial is included below
for you to refer to the sample script
now that we have an instance template we
can create an instance group
using this template create an instance
group
give it a name select multiple zones
under location
this protects us from zonal failures
select a region
and under instance templates select a
template we just created
now set auto scaling mode to auto scale
auto scaling policy to cpu utilization
you can also set policy to http load
balancing or
monitoring metrics we're going to talk
more about http load balancing in a
minute
we will set the target cpu usage to 60
minimum number of instances to three it
is recommended that you provision
enough instances so that if an entire
zone was to go down
the remaining instances still meet the
minimum number required
and set the max number of instances to 6
to make sure you don't incur
additional cost we will set the cooldown
period to 120 seconds
picture of this number is higher than
the time it takes for cpu utilization of
the vm to initially stabilize
we will skip setting a health check for
now or we'll cover that in the next
episode
after that just create wait for a few
minutes until
all the instances are running then go to
vm instances
and click on the external ip of the
instance to see the demo web page
now that we have it all set up let's
generate traffic so we can see the auto
scaling in
action open cloud shell create a local
bash
project using export project id command
run this bash script again that's
included in the link below
this script increases load which leads
to increase in cpu utilization for our
demo app
when it reaches the target value of 60
the auto scaling starts increasing the
size of our instance rule
now let's navigate to our monitoring tab
in our instance group and we can see the
increasing number of instances as the
cpu usage is increasing
and you can see the scaled down effect
by running a similar bash script
that decreases the load leading to
decrease in cpu utilization
and after a few minutes of stabilization
period the auto scaler prompts to
decrease the instance group size
which is visible in the monitoring tab
as well
critter junction has global users they
want the users from singapore to end up
on asia east web server
while the ones in u.s end up on u.s
central region
for this they would use global load
balancing
which routes traffic to the nearest web
server instance
which helps reduce latency and improve
performance
from there the internal load balancer
distributes the traffic to manage
and maintain load across the back ends
these instance groups
in different regions auto scale using an
http load balancing policy
to scale seamlessly regardless of where
the traffic is coming from
not only was critter junction able to
automate the scaling of their compute
instances using auto scaling
and managed instance groups they were
also able to improve
performance by serving traffic from
instances closest to their users
using the global load balancing but
there's one more step to scale
identifying the instances that are
unhealthy and replacing them
automatically
so stay tuned for the next episode where
we will cover how critter junction can
set up auto healing
and keep their users happy and remember
always be architecting
[Music]
you